hannah how are we doing uh so
me and my husband our and our daughter
are planning on going to my husband's
family
for thanksgiving this year and we
recently found out
that one of my husband's family members
uh is actually a sex offender
and we are just kind of mostly me
are trying to process you know do we and
he would probably be at thanksgiving and
we're trying to process through like do
we
you know suck it up and maybe be
uncomfortable
while we're there or do we not
go and maybe risk um some offense with
his family
you just made me make faces okay so
let's back out a little bit when you say
sex offender
define that for me um
i i don't really know the details but i
know
that it happened to someone else
in the family so he did it to someone
else in the family
and it was to the extent that
you know he would go to prison for it
is he going to prison has he been to
prison
um he has not and that's kind of part of
the weird part about it too is that um
it happened a while like not within the
last
couple years okay last year or something
and um so through the process
you know he actually turned himself in
he's
a christian and he turned himself in and
he's really gone through this journey
he told all of his family um but it was
weird because of
covid and everything he went to trial
and the judge actually
gave him like less than a year of hard
labor instead of you know this is
usually like 12 or 13 years in prison
um because he'd really turned a new leaf
and shown
progress and everything but because of
kovid he's actually yet to
walk out that sentence so he's still
free basically so he would be and
they're not going to re
look at it until the new year about
really enforcing that because it would
just a lot of details but because of
that he's not in prison so he would be
at family gatherings so i'm gonna answer
this
as though it was me i have a four and a
half year old daughter
and a ten-year-old son
so i'm gonna frame this with i believe
in redemption for everybody that's the
way i live my life that's the reason i
do this job
as i think there is a lot of darkness in
the world and i think that
everybody has an opportunity to turn it
around
on any given monday tuesday wednesday i
think you can you can make some
significant changes
if you're willing to do the hard hard
work
that said there is a zero percent chance
i would take my family
in this situation to this thanksgiving
outing
period end of story none
and here's why number one
the obvious is that he will be there but
number two
is it appears that he has a family
rallying around him
that is putting him in situations
that are not wise that are not smart and
that are not safe
and when anybody is coming back from any
sort of darkness
whether it's an affair whether it's
addictions whether it
is um they've
they've hurt people like this in
deepened
traumatic and profound ways one of the
cornerstones of success
is people around them that keep them
highly accountable
who are basically a fortress for their
own
stupidity their own hurt their own pain
and their own relational needs
and it doesn't appear that he's got that
and so there is a zero percent chance i
would do that
here's why any wise family would look at
this situation
and say there's gonna be a bunch of kids
here and we'd love to have you back and
we're proud of the work you're making
no chance are you coming to this this is
a part of the decisions
the part of the repercussions of
decisions that you uncle made
and it's going to be years before you
are not welcome back in the family
but that we're going to put you in a
situation with me a bunch of kids
running around here
no chance know-how
and so um you are responsible
and your husband are responsible for
your kids
you can't deal with whatever they're
deciding to do with their family
however insane it is and i'm starting to
get my blood pressure up here
and i don't want that to happen i'm
starting to get fired up a little bit
um and i don't get fired up about a lot
hannah i just don't but this
god almighty this this just pisses me
off um
so you mentioned something in your
original as you were just kind of
talking through this with me and i want
to reframe it for you
you are not going to cause dissension in
the family
by making a decision that you're going
to stay home for thanksgiving and for
christmas
they are
okay and however they frame it however
they spin it however they whatever
they are choosing to not be wise they
are choosing to
ignore they are choosing to um
lean into the hospitality towards a
child molester than they are of their
family members with little kids
and that's just the reality of that
and your husband needs to be the person
that gets up and makes that phone call
that says if uncle so-and-so is going to
be there we're not going to be there
this year
we will continue to watch his progress
and we will continue to cheer him on as
he grows and heals
but this isn't going to be a um
kids aren't going to be the the beta
test case for if whether he's well or
not
not doing that right and that's just
going to be the way that is
and the way you're saying tells me you
don't think that's going to happen
no i'm just processing it um
because you know me and my husband have
talked about how we want to handle it
going forward and
you know he's you know he's processed
through
it and he's you know come to better
terms with it
and you know he's supporting me and
whatever we decide together
and he's okay making those phone calls
and he's you know he said you know
just know like it could do this because
you know his family that is rallied
around uh
this person is saying like he's he's not
dangerous you know he's
you know totally given back his life to
christ
and you know all that stuff and i just
great yeah i'm gonna applaud him and i
if i was talking to your husband here on
the phone
i don't want to get between y'all's
marriage but it's it's
not a fair statement for him to put all
of this onto you
and it's not a fair statement for him to
say well and you know what you're gonna
do
i'll make the call but you know what
this is gonna happen
it's not a cool thing man it's not
you all need to be unified in this and
your kids are not the test case for
whether
um he has fully come around yet
and again i believe in restoration i
believe people turning over leaves i
believe people growing
and saying sorry i am a product of that
the list of jackassery that i've lived
in my life
and the person i try to become new every
day
is happening and happening and happening
right i believe in that
but i'm not gonna my kids are not gonna
be on
the well let's just see we'll trust you
because somebody else trusted him before
and my kids aren't gonna be that test
case and
your husband should proudly and with his
head held high
make that call i get the disappointment
but the disappointment should be
that your uncle's family isn't being
more wise
and that your uncle's family is setting
him up to fail they're putting him in a
position
man he's he better he better do right
right he better he better do right
golly dude this is so frustrating man
i hate you're in the situation hannah
this is one of those situations that
should never happen on 20 different
levels
he shouldn't have hurt kids he should
not be walking around
and god almighty this family shouldn't
be like well it's all good
it's all good let's kind of thanksgiving
let's just put this behind us nope
you don't just put this behind you
you heal from it over a long long period
of time
and i tell you what man i'm keeping my
kids at home
i'm gonna have a friend's giving at home
i'm gonna invite some people over and
we're gonna have a blast
but i'm not doing that thank you so much
for the call hannah
i'm sorry you're in that position um man
get one of those family members to call
me i'd love to talk to them
now i'm sounding like a high school
football player like yeah bro i don't
want to be that guy either
but gosh this pisses me off